l'été est là et avec lui toute sa
farandole de réjouissance mais attention
comme bien souvent derrière chaque
plaisir se cache un danger alors comme
l'année dernière je vais vous
accompagner pendant ces deux mois pour
vous aider à vous faire du bien sans
vous faire du mal tout l'été des tc vous
aident à éviter les pièges et les
dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et
votre santé
dtc partenaire de votre été le soleil
c'est vachement bien ça donne bonne mine
ça donne le sourire ça peut soigner
certaines maladies peau et ça nous aide
même à synthétiser la vitamine d et ça
c'est bon pour les os pour les muscles
et même pour le coeur mais c'est comme
toutes les bonnes choses
c'est à consommer avec modération sinon
ça pique
[Applaudissements]
et où ils revers de la médaille sollers
et les coups de soleil ce qu'on attrape
quand on s'endort sur la plage ou qu'on
a envie de bronze est beaucoup trop vite
mais bon on va prendre les choses dans
l'ordre
alors déjà vous allez me demander
pourquoi on bronze à quoi ça sert ben
oui pourquoi en bronze
à quoi ça sert à ça faisait longtemps
tiens ça n'aurait manqué ça ouais donc
bon à part pécho la buvette du camping à
quoi ça sert
et bah paradoxalement on bronze pour se
protéger du soleil
oui parce qu'on va en parler un peu plus
tard mais le soleil c'est dangereux
notamment pour la peau le soleil émet un
certain nombre de rayons et notamment
des rayons ultraviolets rayons uv et
dans notre épiderme c'est à dire la
couche superficielle de notre peau il ya
des cellules qu'on appelle les
mélanocytes et qui réagissent à ces
sujets quand elles y sont exposés elle
produit d'un pigment qui s'appelle la
mélanine qui remonte à la surface qui
forme une couche coloré qui absorbe les
uv et les empêchent d'aller faire des
dégâts plus profond et comme en plus les
uv agissent aussi sur d'autres cellules
qu'on appelle les kératinocytes qui
entraîne un épaississement de la peau on
est doublement protéger ça s'appelle la
photoprotection même on entre dans le
vif du sujet un coup de soleil
c'est quoi alors vous n'allez peut-être
pas me croire mais attrapé un coup de
soleil c'est se transformer en mutant ni
plus ni moins je m'explique à forte dose
les uv et principalement les uv b
modifie le code génétique de nos
cellules qui mute donc et qui meurt du
coup notre système immunitaire qui est
un peu la jambe sécu l'organisme si vous
voulez il se dit est ce que c'est
l'expression chez nous les mecs la base
on
du soleil son traitement les gars ça
dégage tout le monde dehors donc pour
évacuer tout ce petit monde et pour
réparer les dégâts
le corps déclenché une bonne vieille
réactions inflammatoires
ce qui explique tous les stigmates du
coup de soleil c'est rouge
c'est chaud et ça fait mal si vous
voulez rentrer un petit peu plus dans le
détail du mécanisme je vous conseille
les vidéos de tania de la chaîne
biologie tout compris dont je vous mets
les liens dans la description comment
éviter les coups de soleil
alors on va se mettre d'accord tout de
suite je vous le dit tout de go le
concept de préparer sa peau au soleil
c'est du caca de taureaux
bullshit comme on dit aux states dans
les cabines de bronzage vous êtes
exposés à des uv artificiels qui colore
votre peau mais qui ne stimule pas la
production de mélanine
donc ça ne vous protège pas ça peut même
être dangereux parce que même avec les
dernières réglementations les médecins
estiment que les uv artificiels sont
responsables de cancers de la peau du
côté des autobronzants et des
compléments alimentaires divers et
variés pareil ça vous permet d'avoir le
teint hâlé un petit peu avant de vous
exposer au soleil mais ça ne vous
protège pas du tout donc concrètement le
seul moyen de se protéger des coups de
soleil fait d'éviter de s'exposer à une
trop grande quantité d'uv surtout au
début quand on a la première manche
notamment entre 12h et 16h puisque c'est
là qu'elle est la plus importante donc à
couvrez-vous deux laissez votre peau se
reposer un peu évitez de rester trop
longtemps au soleil et 3 mettez de la
crème sans plus attendre je vous propose
un petit point kramer fait truc à
retenir sur la crème solaire
[Musique]
mettez en toutes les deux heures et
après chaque baignade et à chaque fois
que vous avez beaucoup transpiré mettez
la dose des couches épaisses sur toutes
les zones qui vont être exposés trente
minutes avant d'aller au soleil mais
thézan même si vous êtes à londres parce
que les uv se réverbère sur un certain
nombre de surfaces comme l'eau ou le
sable par exemple souvenez-vous que
l'écran total fait quel que soit
l'indicé de protection il ya toujours un
peu du v qui passent d'ailleurs
l'appellation écran total lé internet
choisissez votre indice de protection en
fonction de la nature de votre peau plus
elle est clair moins vous avez de
photoprotection naturel plus il vous
faut un indice élevé sachez que les
crèmes indices six filtres 84% des uv
les indices 25 96% et les indices 30 et
50 respectivement 97 et 98 %
les indices annoncées concernent les uvb
c'est à dire ceux qui donnent
principalement les coups de soleil
mais les uv à provoque aussi des cancers
de la peau donc demandé une crème qui
filtre les deux et quand c'est trop tard
on fait quoi bon vous ne vous êtes pas
protégés ou mal fabrique pas là pour
juger mais la réalité est implacable
vous avez choper un coup de soleil alors
vous faites quoi dans un premier temps
vous pleurnichez 1
parce que ça pique évidemment mais
surtout vous allez vous mettre à l'abri
et vous arrêtez de vous exposer au
soleil et la base une fois que vous êtes
allons vous en profitez pour boire
beaucoup pour éviter la déshydratation
de l'eau on est d'accord déjà cramé
dehors vous allez pas me cramer dedans
et si vous pouvez vous rafraîchissez la
zone brûlée avec de l'eau fraîche mais
pas trop froide
jean 15 20 degrés ensuite tout dépend de
l'étendue des dégâts
si c'est juste un peu rouge et que la
douleur est supportable un peu de lotion
après soleil ça fera bien la faire si
c'est bien rouge et que ça chauffe c'est
quand même un saut chez le pharmacien il
vous donnera sûrement une pommade pour
soigner les brûlures
et si vraiment vous supportez plus vos
vêtements si le coup de soleil et très
étendues genre l'équivalent de 10 fois
la paume de votre main et surtout s'il
ya des grosses cloques et encore plus si
vous ressentez des signes genre
des maux de tête vertiges et cetera
faites-vous accompagner chez le médecin
oui conduisait pas vous en avez assez
fait comme ça quoi qu'il arrive par la
suite ne permet pas les cloques
je vous connais vous allez faire ça
commence à moins oui parce que ça risque
de s'infecter la limite si vraiment
c'est gênant retourner voir votre
nouveau meilleur ami
le pharmacien et demandez-lui du
matériel stérile pour les vies des
genres aiguilles pansements etc et bien
sûr tant que c'est pas guéri vous ne
vous exposez pas au soleil
voilà pour les coups de soleil mais il
ya encore quelque chose que vous devez
savoir si on s'expose beaucoup au soleil
les uv a et les uvb abîme les cellules
de la peau et peuvent provoquer des
cancers
même si on n'a pas pris de coup de
soleil et avoir la peau naturellement
foncé ou est déjà bronzée ça diminue les
listes mais il existe quand même donc de
manière générale ne passez pas votre
temps en plein soleil en plus affaiblir
la peau plus vite et ça donne des rides
ah oui avant de se quitter une dernière
chose n'oubliez pas aussi de protéger
vos yeux
mais attention mettez pas ne mettez pas
de la crème solaire dessus un métier
plutôt des lunettes et choisissez des
verts qui filtre bien les usa
voilà ce premier détester spécialité est
terminé on se retrouve dans deux
semaines pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là prenez soin de vous prenez soin
de vos yeux prenez soin de votre peau
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]